[Musique]
tu sais ce qu'est un Arlequin le
rôle des Arlequins c'est de servir c'est rien
sans un maître on s'en
fout qu'on soit au-delà de la mort
le Joker et j'ai rompu je voulais un
nouveau départ mais il s'avère que je n'étais pas
le  seul démon les a fait chercher l'
émancipation
oculaire nouvelle reine elle m'a jeté
[Applaudissements]
qui vous avez
[Musique] dont
vous avez besoin
après nous tous maintenant
ou en sortant d'ici
nous devrions commander une pizza parce que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui passe un bon moment
nous utiliserons un cercle jerk Je n'appellerais jamais une
femme une nana J'accepterai la fraude dame
femme mais à l'occasion [ __ ] H s'il vous plaît
devez déplacer ça de toute façon
vous